I just wanted to bring you this quote  from a more generally which is perhaps  more relevant this comes from a  conservative leave MP who I think will  be back in Boris Johnson in the  leadership contest he told me this he  said I said to him so where's the plan  can we see the brexit plan now  there is no plan the leave campaign  don't have a post Bridget plan and and  he was pointing over there to where the  vote leave H key walls and he then he  pointed over there and he said number 10  should have had a plan now it sounds  like I'm making that up that literally  happened two hours ago  so and I've said this before the person  with the most fought through plan as  evidenced by the past 48 hours is  astonishingly Nicola Sturgeon the First  Minister of Scotland